[Music]
looks like quarantine has Britney Spears
thinking about her ex Brittany did just
that on Instagram Wednesday rocking out
to Justin Timberlake's 2018 single
filthy in the caption Brittany wrote in
part I know we had one of the world's
biggest breakups twenty years ago but
hey the man is a genius
great song JT technically they broke up
18 years ago but who's counting Justin
of course caught wind of the post and
replied with one laughing with tears of
joy emoji and three praise emojis it's
always nice to kind of feel that energy
the 38 year old pop icon also joked in
the post that the video was her version
of snapchat or tick-tock or whatever the
cool thing you're supposed to do these
days she even posted a follow-up video
with the same song playing and
Brittany's current boyfriend Sam muscari
didn't seem to mind Brits shout-out to
her ex he commented on the post calling
her an inspiration it was really
important just to spread joy you know
and be a happy person this isn't the
first time Brittany shown JT love in
2016 she gave him this shoutout and they
both say they'd be down for a Mickey
Mouse Club reunion
so in separate interviews Kristina and
Brittany said they would be down for a
reunion would you ever be down sure so
you would have to plan I would
definitely show up I would go definitely
it was probably one of the most special
times in my life as a Mickey Mouse Club
Britney if you're feeling nostalgic
we've got you covered starting out with
that iconic double denim date night at
the 2001 American Music Awards how do
you do it day in and day out um you know
what we have fun we love what we're
doing so it doesn't even feel like work
seriously you know I love what I do so
that's
yeah yeah I agree you know I mean we're
weird you know lucky individuals to get
to do something that we love to do you
know not many people can say that
so me where you're not gonna see us
complainant we're having a good time
[Music]
sort of kicking back and relaxing
tonight having a good time oh yeah we
don't get to do a lot so it's definitely
good for her she's been you know this
all week she thinks I'm a funny ass dude
[Music]
most the time I don't because she's nice
she laughs he really is funny
[Music]